hey guys this is andrew for
trainingsensors.com so very quickly let
me introduce myself i'm a professional
trader and i've just started to make
some youtube videos
where i try to explain to you guys
everything that i usually do at work to
set up my trades
so i mostly use technical analysis but
also read the flows
read the option market and any
information that can help me to build up
my view
so in this video i want to make an
update on the cons so bitcoin ethereum
and dutch coin
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so which one should i
start with let's start with the dutch
coin because this is the one that
everybody's talking about
i like to do coins because you know
they're easy seriously they don't have
any fundamentals and
they are just following for me the
technical analysis that everybody is
using to trade those
you know they are kind of you know pump
and dump assets
especially for the dutch con you know
which value is
really nothing but still it's going
higher and you can check the videos i
did one or two weeks ago i think i think
i did two videos on dutch coin
and it was during this correction and i
was telling you guys that we are bullish
that the fifth wave is coming
and it's gonna be powerful and it's
gonna go to zero i said open nine
then i said 0.8 when i saw this
dip so i did my first video here second
here
and 0.8 is still my target but let's
update
that you know this is a target they give
from when we were at 0.3
now that we are at 0.7 i have more
information
so let's check this information and see
what we can deduce
so very quickly the first reason guys i
was bullish is just idiot wave counting
i do my counting one two three four five
each motive wave can be broken down in
five waves and each corrective waves can
be broken down in abc's
three waves corrective patterns and here
it's quite clean i can do it
properly so i'm kind of convinced that
this is a fifth wave
now where is it going i can use fib
extensions and i can also do some idiot
wave counting
inside of it so if i use fib extension
this is what i showed you guys already
you measured the third wave you applied
to the bottom of the force wave and you
go to the 1.618
right so 0.78 you can also go to the
2.618 this can happen all right
so we have just one information is that
this is kind of the minimum we would go
to
before some correction then i know that
elon musk is talking tomorrow and guys
you know the saying by the rumor sell
the news
so people like to buy because they think
something is going to happen but once it
is actually happening usually that is
appointed and they are now that we know
that even if it's good
what else are we going to have to
actually bring up
bring some uh hope and bullish momentum
nothing because the news has passed good
or bad
this is you know the psychological
mechanisms that are
actually taking place when we have this
kind of announcements
so i'm from those you know who've seen
that many times and
i think that the market is going to drop
just before elon musk
is talking or just right after you know
roughly when he's going to talk
but for now we are not there yet let's
analyze this fifth wave so let me get
rid of it
let's zoom in on the hourly timeframe
and let's see what idiot wave is telling
us here so i didn't do
it before guys i'm gonna do it right
away with you
we are trying to find five waves one
two definitely this is three
so i'm not sure if the three is done or
not
so i'm gonna go inside my three change
the color
okay and i'm gonna change the color
later and i'm gonna do the same thing
one
two three
okay this one is easy to get this is a
four this is a five one two
three four five all right so this looks
like
okay let me change the color
um i know this is a four because this is
a triangle guys when you spot a triangle
you know it's a four
so this is a four so then this is a
three so up one two three four five so
here you can see
i can do the same thing
all right then so you just do it like
this guys i have not done this before
so i'm doing it right now with you up
one two three four five one two three
four five here
so this is a three and my one is
supposed to do one two three four five
as well
so it's something like this one two
three four five all right this is
working
so then what do we have this is a two so
one
two so this is a three perfect we have
it
one two three four five all right this
one is not very clean but
let's accept it like it is three
okay so we're doing a four
okay so now i got few information guys
new information is that possible that
i'm missing something here
so we are only in the third wave i was
checking if
actually you know this third wave could
be here
so this is the question i'm having you
know do we have
on the short term one or two more moves
up to come
at least one maybe two
and to know that i need to know if this
could work
so can it be five actually
then one would be the three i don't see
it i'm wondering if i can have a
fifth wave here so then my false wave
okay this would be then like this
now it's not working you see it's not
working so i have two more moves to come
guys
all right
i first need to finish the fifth wave
that is probably going to go to 0.8
then we're going to correct a bit deeper
and then we're going to have one last
move up all right
and this is gonna be the fifth wave
complete so then this one last move up
might go to the next feed
retracement so we would do it slowly but
we can do it like here measure the third
wave here and apply it to the bottom
wherever it will be
right so maybe something like this or we
can do it
with the fifth wave here the third wave
here
and do the same thing so one two three
four five
uh that the third wave is here
and we having different information all
right so we don't know where the third
wave is gonna go
so let's see we're gonna have different
targets we're gonna
improvise when the market is gonna
giving us more
uh information more data for now what i
can tell you guys
is that i see uh this fifth wave that is
not complete i think we're on the third
wave of the fifth
and so we're gonna have one more move up
then one correction and then
one last move up maybe going around 150
you know the 150 area so actually this
is maybe going to be the correction with
the by the rumors of the news
and then actually there's going to be
one more move up because ellen musk
would have said something amazing that's
possible
let's quickly have a look at the bitcoin
guys i i told you that i was
bearish on this one i said that one or
two weeks ago
this is what i see all right we're
having here the ending diagonal
so let me just show you quickly again on
the daily time frame on the daily time
frame we had here the force
and here the fifth wave doing a
beautiful ending diagonal with a wedge
pattern all right this was
before the 15th of april so when we
broke the watch pattern around the 15th
20th of april i told you guys we are
correcting and this is going to last for
month
then we having here this one two three
four five so let's go on the forwards
we having here the one two three four
five uh usually the correction is going
to be five
three five so one two three four five
okay
abc here going to 59 000
it's a lot i thought we would correct
around 55 57
000 we went to 59 but it doesn't change
much to my
analysis we're still we still did a one
abc
three waves so right now i'm expecting
guys a one two three four five
going down going to 42 000 and this is
gonna happen
soon so maybe this week or next week so
let's see if i'm
right about that if i am then i'm
probably gonna be right as well about
what is gonna be
gonna come next which is a flat
correction so my scenario is that first
we go to 42 000 we bounce back to the
all-time highs
we go again here and we around june july
we then do the final move up all right
that is gonna bring us to the
you know the 100 000 area probably
slightly above
and ethereum the last one so here i just
wanted to show something
i did the video but i didn't post it
because i was too late guys
just to show you the difference between
the ethereum and the bitcoin
something very interesting is that on
the bitcoin
here you know we have this watch pattern
and
so it's going to daily we had the switch
pattern
so forget about all the drawings only
focus on this here is the wedge pattern
guys
here and here all this one two three
four five in yellow
and you can see that here between the
one and the five the market is going
higher
you know but with less energy than it
used to
before this is why the macd is going
lower and here we had
this beautiful bearish divergence guys i
told you about that as well
i gave you this divergence uh you know a
long time ago
around here around the 5th of march guys
you can go and check my videos i told
you that this
is the final wave anyway i knew we would
go down i mean
there was a high probability we break it
on the downside
and that we do a corrective pattern and
on the
ethereum guys i just checked this last
week and i didn't post my videos so you
can trust me on the trust me
but what is sure is that you don't have
this uh
bearish divergence i think the same
dates here the market is going higher
just like for bitcoin
but the macd is going higher as well not
a lot
i agree but the macd is going higher as
well so there is no divergence and
here we have this strong move up so the
question is
where might we be heading as usual guys
i do my counting i'm not going to show
you
this in very detail in this video
because i
unfortunately don't have time i need to
go to work but you measure the third
wave
you apply to the bottom of the force
wave and you check your ratios
and the most likely one the 1.618
is 4364. so let's call it
4300 so i think we are going to go
in this area before maybe correcting
more and once again
i'm going to go on the shorter term to
do some more illiot wave
counting and to try to see if this is
fitting so
just very quickly and then i'm going to
do it right now with you
very quickly so one two
three four all right so this is a fifth
wave you can see
this is easier than the dutch coin
because the patterns actually cleaner
one two three four five all right you
can see right away
then abc
put this one in green
okay then one two three four five
and then here a flat guys it's like
perfect
once again you can see that we are
respecting
all the elliot waves rule is that when
you have a correct a zigzag in the
second wave you usually have a flat
in the third wave and here we having our
five waves as well
so this counting is very clean once
again guys
as it always is on the cryptocurrencies
that are very good to use and right now
when the fifth wave and i'm pretty sure
the fifth wave is going to 4
300 by doing a one two three
four five all right so this is my view 4
300 on the 17th of may then we correct
let's see if this is correct i gave you
my view on the dutch coin i gave you my
view on the bitcoin that is bearish and
on the ethereum that is
bullish so guys that's it for me i hope
you enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to show see you guys